nothing's working with this
administration inflation now 9.1 percent
that's at least what they're telling us
which most likely means it's worse than
that and you know when cnn is covering
it then something really ain't right
horrible news for your wallet new data
today released by the biden
administration shows inflation surging
to 9.1
that is the highest level in more than
40 years and it means the prices we pay
overall are 9.1 percent higher than they
were at this time last year so unless
you have benefited from an unlikely 10
raise since then
you now have less money in your pocket
than you did a year ago
much of the increase is driven by gas
prices which we should note have fallen
in recent weeks but they remain insanely
high up nearly 60 percent in this report
and the increases are felt across a
range of categories prices on groceries
are up more than 10 percent housing
nearly six percent
today president biden admitting that
inflation is still quote unacceptably
high vice president harris saying there
is no question we still have work to do
little consolation
to the millions of americans who are
struggling to make ends meet due to
rising prices across the board
chad i'm not a math a magician over here
but uh
is it crazy to say that if you print a
whole bunch of money based in nothing
and you just keep printing it that you
might devalue the existing money because
then there's suddenly more of it and i
have some recollection of something
called supply and demand i don't want to
confuse people on a friday but do you
think that maybe they did this
you know i've said for for a while now
that this is the controlled crash of the
plane they're bringing it down they
intend to crash it they want to survive
it themselves but
what they're doing in terms of creating
as i alluded to earlier this adherence
to a modern monetary theory where
deficits and debt are a good thing if
you go back you look at the green new
deal when the green new deal first came
out i thought it was something written
in crayons by a fifth grader i said
there's no way you can't do a 90
trillion dollar overhaul infrastructure
uh rebuild you can't you can't do all of
these things that you know they were
proposing that you want to do and then i
started realizing when it comes to
modern monetary theory they can do it
because you don't have to back up this
system uh you centralize everything you
devalue everything and we're starting to
see it played out we're seeing it played
out in the stock market we're seeing it
played out in crypto currencies
everything is being brought back to the
feds and they're the ones who are in
control the ideologues on the left the
progressive wild eyes as i call them you
know the your billionaires your gates
your zuckerbergs your soros's they're
the ones who are pulling the strings
whoever's pulling their strings i don't
know but these folks don't like you they
don't love you they want to see this
thing crash and america is has been the
bastion of of independence that has
stood in their way so we're a direct
target look we're headed towards barrels
of oil that'll be 300 325 dollars a
barrel uh what are you gonna do when
it's ten dollars eleven dollars for for
a gallon of gas
they don't mind that because in the end
this is the result they're trying to
bring about
chad i appreciate your calmed measured
answer there but i've got video right
here we're going to show you biden said
this is just temporary don't worry
the overwhelming consensus is going to
pop up a little bit and then go back
down
no one's talking about
this great great thing it's highly
unlikely that it's going to be long-term
inflation
kurt you heard him no one's talking
about this great great you know
yet here we are
well i you know far be it for me to
criticize president corn holyoke but
uh this
you know i i
there there is something to be said to
uh the clara proven effect where you
where you let everything fall to pieces
so you can rebuild it in your own image
that happened when i was much younger uh
with jimmy carter running uh the united
states into the ground uh socially
politically militarily now
um
of course jimmy carter is the only one
happy about the biden presidency because
now he's not the worst president of the
last century
but we got reagan
and reagan showed us how to deal how to
deal with the soviets how to deal with
inflation
the the fact that these guys are driving
us into the ground dave
is an opportunity we should never let a
crisis go to waste because they are
teaching us about the intellectual
bankruptcy of modern monetary thinking
they are teaching us uh the end game of
the climate change hoax they are get
they are going to run america the ground
and we got two more years of this
that we may just win over a new
generation of americans now we're never
going to win over the uh chardonnay
swilling wine women of suburbia
we're not going to win them we're not
going to win the faculty lounge crew
we're not gonna
win over the activists but you know
we're we're we're winning over uh latinx
americans
uh working class americans
uh
it it's going to truly be a realignment
and you know if some idiot comes down
the road in 20 years and says there's
this thing called modern modern monetary
theory and we should spend everyone's
just going to go shut up i lived through
9.1 inflation i gave 9.1 to the big guy
no thanks